That's the trunked radio pillar.
Five ideas, and they interlock: a pool of
shared channels, a control channel
coordinating it, talkgroups giving users a
stable identity, grants moving each call
to its channel — and FDMA or TDMA deciding
how those channels share the spectrum.
Everything else in trunking — multisite
networks, roaming, encryption, the
protocol wars between P25, DMR, and TETRA
— builds on these five.
When you're ready, those are waiting in
the Field Guide.
Every segment's full write-up is linked
below, with diagrams and sources.
If this helped, the whole Field Guide is
free at gophertrunk dot org — and
GopherTrunk itself, the open-source
trunking scanner this course is built
around, is on GitHub.
Thanks for watching.